foreign
Matthew is with us in Los Angeles hi
Matthew welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up in your world
well have a couple of quick questions
um first of all
um I have a annuity slash 401k plan
um and there's about close to a million
dollars in there and I got this letter
from the organization and they have this
program and it's called a single life
annuity and is I'll read it to you it
says that pays you a fixed amount of
money each month for the rest of your
life
and then it says following your death no
payments will be made to your spouse of
your heirs so the estimated payment that
they'll pay me under that condition is
forty three hundred dollars a month now
they also offer
that sucks
right 48 000 on a million dollars 4.8
percent return on your million dollars
and then you lose all your money at
death
well this is the thing um I I I don't
know if I you misunderstood they're
going to pay me yes they're gonna pay me
forty three hundred dollars a month yeah
forty eight thousand dollars a year okay
that's correct yeah you do quick math
okay okay but they also but they also
offer that for a lesser amount which
will be 3 600 a month that
um I can uh my spouse will be able to
continue at that amount that's so sweet
of her life that's so sweet so they're
going to screw you again yeah no all
right no no and no no no and no and no
and no no no this is a million dollar
mistake
okay so have you got a fireplace have
you got a fireplace by chance uh I do
yeah okay good you can use this letter
for kindling
okay well see the thing is is that and
that's kind of my question is you're
always concerned on how long you're
going to live now I mean
um is I mean I'm concerned that you're a
million dollars poorer
when you die after only getting a 4.8
return on your money
okay that concerns me
when you could have been in good mutual
funds averaging a 10 rate of return and
when you die the million dollars is
still there
right right right oh so this is like a
well it's like you're you're accepting
half the money you should be getting per
month and you lose all of your money at
retirement and they wink and Nod and act
like they're doing you a favor
this is laughable I I think the reason
that they bring this forward is because
a lot of folks don't like to have to
deal with you know
the reason they bring It Forward is
anybody that's dumb enough to do it
they're screwing them out of a million
dollars that's the reason they bring It
Forward
it is not well they they present it as
as being convenient for you yeah well
yeah yeah you have a guarantee you're
guaranteed to be screwed
yeah okay I mean seriously well if you
can let listen I mean if you the stock
market is averaged 11.8 since it began
but if it does half
of what it is averaged
for the next 20 years
you are still going to have more money
per month and then leave your heirs a
million dollars
more than these goobers are offering you
you understand the difference
yeah well
well still you know it's not taxed yet I
mean you know I haven't pulled it out so
I mean it's it's not I do know that and
I do know that your income is going to
be taxed as you pull it off per the
income but I wasn't even going to touch
the million I was going to live off of
the return it created and it just sits
there right
and guess what it's not taxed yeah so
there you go yeah that no no no no no no
when a life insurance company says we
are here to help you in general it's
like the government saying we are here
to help you in both cases you should
scream set your hair on fire and run out
of the room
right yeah and I think I mean play into
that can
conductor I think a lot of people feel
overwhelmed and they're like we'll take
care of you don't worry about you know
you could live 30 more years and we'll
make sure you're taken care of but it's
not really the reality of the situation
they're not there to to be super
generous to you another way of looking
at Matthew is is you wouldn't have a
million dollars
if you have been using their products to
grow your wealth
you wouldn't even have this problem the
fact that you were self-sufficient
well and it's like if you want to have
that convenience factor if you are
feeling a little bit overwhelmed with
your finances and you have savings then
talk to a Smart Master Pro I mean that's
someone who can take that overwhelm and
guide you into to things that are really
going to grow your money and help you in
the long run
being broke is always inconvenient
having half the money you should have is
inconvenient that's inconvenience so uh
no don't don't look for a babysitter
don't look for a magic wand manage your
money make your money behave live off of
the income
I mean a million dollars creating a 10
rate of return is a hundred thousand
dollars a year not fifty thousand
dollars a year yeah
well and just the fees on these products
are ridiculous I was just talking with
my in-laws about this over Thanksgiving
and they were talking about annuities
and showing me some of the paperwork and
it's like whoo
that is ridiculous even if there is a
death benefit it is not great yeah yeah
and it's just um so the best thing to do
is to run from these people as fast as
you possibly can do your investing in
good Investments and good Investments
are never found at life insurance
companies
do not go to the transmission store to
fix your muffler
they work on Transmissions life
insurance people should be in the Life
Insurance business they got in the
investment business because they figured
out it was a way to screw people and
that's what this is anytime you pay
someone half of what they should be
getting per month and then you keep
their money when they die that by
definition is screwing them
and so if you don't like it and you're
in that business you should get in
another business and that way I won't
say you're screwing people like Dave
Ramsey Dave Ramsey said you're a crook
okay that's what Dave Ramsey just said I
stand up for the consumer I don't give a
flip what you think if you work for a
life insurance company you can just
pound sand right and so that was nice I
cleaned that up considerable but the um
no seriously uh I I you know there's
there's entire websites devoted from the
life insurance world that hate on Dave
Ramsey and I am
blessed by that fact
because that means that I'm standing up
for the consumer instead of you out
there you listeners uh and because I am
not taking a poll with those morons oh
my gosh no really seriously go handle
your own money you'll have more money
during life you'll have more money
during death ride the roller coaster
yourself they're writing it and keeping
the change while you sit there and take
the uh the lint out of your pocket and
that's all you get